[Music]
what if there is a way that you could
capture all the benefits of annular
material but customize the behavior and
styling in an unaffiliated way well
that's exactly what angular's component
development kit does in today's video
you'll learn how to build a reactive cdk
data table that implements its own
custom behaviors and also uses bootstrap
4 for its CSS styling if you're new to
the channel make sure to LIKE and
subscribe and the code for this video is
produced by Zack DeRose who is a senior
team lead working on angular over at
Swamp Fox Inc
make sure to check out his full article
on medium because it goes into some
advanced stuff that I don't cover here
such as searching sorting and applying
styles on a cell-by-cell basis I'm
starting out from the state regular
angular 6 app and the first thing I'll
do is install the component development
kit which is at angular slash cdk then
I'll generate a component called table
from there I'll jump over to the app
module and we'll want to import the data
table from angular cdk then add the cdk
table module to the imports array the
first table we'll build is pretty basic
and ugly but what it's doing under the
hood is pretty powerful
and without the cdk this would take a
lot more code than it does in this video
I'll be working with some dummy data
throughout this video which I have saved
in this data Ts file first we have an
array of column names which just define
the names of the columns in the table
and then we have the actual data which
is a map of various heroes and each hero
has a set of properties that match these
column names so basically this simulates
some initial data that you might pull
from a back-end database or API now
let's jump into the component and start
putting together this table I'm going to
go pretty slow through this code because
I want to talk about behavior subjects
and observables because they're very
powerful structures when working with
tables a behavior subject is really
useful when you have a value that you
want to manually change over time they
work just like an observable but they
always have a current value and you can
push new values to them and you can
always get the current value in place
which means you kind of have the best of
both worlds between observables and just
regular JavaScript
what's also really cool is that you can
use your behavior subject as a single
source of truth that gets mapped to
other observables for example we'll be
able to map this heroes dictionary down
to an array of data that we can loop
over in our data table for each row and
we'll build up to some more advanced use
cases with that concept later in the
video so if you want to take your single
source of truth and map it to just a
regular observable you can do that by
just calling pipe and then adding some
operators to structure it in the way
that you need for the UI in this case we
just want to map the dictionary down to
an array of values which we can do with
object dot values so now we have an
observable array of data that we can
loop over in the table you may have
noticed that I was clicking a button in
the table that was changing the values
for a given row that's also made
possible by the reactive nature of
behavior subjects and observables we can
grab the value of our behavior subject
by simply calling value on it and
because it's an object we can then grab
the hero name that's being clicked on
and update its values to level up the
hero will simply increment each one of
its properties by one from there we can
compose a new object by using the spread
syntax and taking that current value
from the behavior subject then overwrite
the value for the clicked hero so
that'll be the next value for our
behavior subject and everything else
that depends on it will react
accordingly and we can simply push that
into the stream by calling next now we
can jump into the component HTML and
we'll see that the cdk gives us a whole
bunch of different directives that we
can use to bind our data to the table
the most important one is the data
source which is that observable that we
mapped our behavior subject to in the
type script the next thing we'll do is
define the header row and because we
already have an array of the column
names we can just pass that in as the
cdk header row definition after that we
will make a definition for each actual
row in the table and that's going to
automatically loop over every item in
our data source array now the last major
step is to define the logic for each
cell in the row you could loop over each
cell or you can define them one by one
since we have some custom behavior we'll
just go ahead and declare each one of
our cells one by one
all we have to do is define what the
header should look like then we have
access to the underlying data object
which is in the template variable of Rho
so this cell will have a header of hero
name and then the actual value will be
the row name then we'll just go ahead
and repeat this logic over and over
again until we get to the actual cell
that has the clickable button the
special thing about this cell is that
we're not actually displaying a value
but instead we'll have a clickable
button that will trigger that level up
event handler that we define in the type
script to level up a hero we need to
know its name which we have access to
through the row template variable which
we can then pass in to our level up
method as the argument and just like
that we have a data table that relies on
a single source of truth for its input
which is a pattern that you really want
if you're going to scale up in
complexity just imagine trying to apply
the same pattern and plain JavaScript or
jQuery you'd have a lot more code to
write but for your end users this is
still a pretty ugly table let's see how
we might add some better styling to it
for that we'll use bootstrap for but you
could use any other CSS framework or
your own styles completely you can grab
the CSS for bootstrap from the website
and then paste it into the head of the
document in the index.html file and
angular then back in the bootstrap Docs
you'll see a variety of different styles
for tables pick whichever one you like
and you'll also want a style for the
button in that table as well so as you
might imagine adding styles to our cdk
table is easy as any other HTML table we
simply add the class name and we're good
to go so now we have a table that
behaves like angular material but looks
like bootstrap
but I want to take this a step further
and I want to highlight the hero with
the highest and lowest health rating and
I want that style to be updated
reactively whenever the values change in
this table let's see how we can leverage
our existing behavior subject to handle
this for us I'm also going to install
the max by and min by methods from
lodash to make this code a little bit
more concise these functions are really
useful if you have an array of objects
and you need to calculate some
statistics about a certain property on
those objects which in this case we want
to find that heroes with the men and
health from there we'll go ahead and
define a new observable called min max
and this will be tied to our hero source
behavior subject but this time we want
to map it down to just the two heroes
one with the men and one with the max
health so what we're doing here is
computing a value based on a single
source of truth that will update
reactively inside of map we can simply
use lodash to find the hero with the max
health and then the hero with the min
health and then we'll just return the
names of those two heroes so we can use
them in our HTML now angular has a
built-in ng class directive that we can
use to easily update the styles based on
this logic we pass ng class an object
where the key of that object is the CSS
class that we want to apply this class
is from bootstrap which is BG success
which will give the row a green
highlight and then we'll unwrap the min
Max observable and if the max equals
this row name then we'll go ahead and
highlight it then we'll do the same
exact thing for the min value except
this time we'll apply the BG danger
which will give it a red highlight and
that's all there is to it we now have
reactive CSS Styles being applied to our
data table if your tables have huge
amounts of data then you'll probably
need to paginate it so let's look into
how we can further leverage rxjs
to make a reactive pagination system to
simplify the UI elements I'm going to
use ng bootstrap but you could
definitely do this from scratch as well
first we'll install it via NPM then go
into the app module and add it to the
imports array there it gives us access
to a pagination component and we just
need to pass it a few input variables to
make it work it needs to know the total
size of our collection which is just the
length of our data source array then it
needs to know how many items we want to
show on each page it also needs to know
the current page which will also be a
behavior subject when we get to the
typescript and lastly it needs an event
handler so when the user clicks on a new
page it updates to the correct page and
a little trick when you're using a
behavior subject is instead of writing
an event handler you can just call
current page next with that event as
long as the event is what you actually
need to send in the stream and the last
change we'll make is set the data source
to a new observable called data on pages
which is a slice of the
actual values that we want to show so
we'll need to add a couple of new
properties to our component to make all
this work the first one is the current
page which is a behavior subject and
it's a behavior subject because we want
to react to it and we also want to
change it dynamically from there we have
a data on page observable which will
react to changes in the data source of
Heroes and also the current page and
lastly the page size which is just a
number the hardest part is defining the
slice of data that we want to show for
each page we need to react to page
changes so we'll go ahead and pipe an
observable that's based off the current
page behavior subject but the actual
data source is the hero's behavior
subject so we can use the switch map
operator to switch to that data source
so at this point we know that current
page as well as the array of heroes and
we just need to map it down to a slice
to display on that page we can figure
out which items to display on the page
by taking that current page value
subtracting one and then multiplying it
by the page size that's the starting
index then the ending index is just that
starting index plus the page size and
those are the two arguments that we'll
use to slice the array if we go back to
our data table you'll see that it's only
displaying two items per page but it's
also maintaining the styling logic that
we set up in the previous step and again
this is possible because we're using a
single data source and having everything
else react to a coordinate light I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you're serious about
building angular apps consider becoming
a pro member at angular firebase com
you'll get a free copy of my book as
well as one on one project support
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
soon